[Music]
tonight's cybersafe parent carries a
message for parents who are business
owners or who work in large companies
cyber attacks can happen at any point
and sometimes the cyber hijackers are
looking for a ransom
ransomware is when you have a cyber
criminal or somebody else that
essentially is able to hack into your
system last week hackers targeted
software that powers the websites of
some 5 000 schools they start encrypting
your data that you have on your computer
if hackers are breaking through the
firewall of a business this is an impact
in an employee or two it can be company
wide compromises their their servers all
of their data all of their customers
files
their employee files in the first week
of the new year ransomware caused health
care workers in jacksonville florida to
have their pay delayed a county in
albuquerque new mexico has been forced
offline and are still working to regain
control over their computers and in
columbus ohio a business breach affected
nearly 5 000 people their credit card
numbers all stolen they encrypt that
data sometimes they'll exfiltrate it
meaning that they they send it to their
server so they save a copy of it and
then what they'll do is they'll use that
to extort money from you the message is
clear pay the ransom or we keep the data
and then if you refuse to pay that
ransom then the next thing they'll do is
they'll try to blackmail you and say hey
look if you don't give us 500 000
then we're also going to release all of
this personal identifying information of
your customers and your employees on the
dark web and give it to all the
criminals that are out there so what is
the best ransomware defense experts
recommend a wide-ranging approach
including multi-factor authentication
using cutting-edge cyber security
updating software and restricting
administrative privileges they also say
be wary of emails provide security
awareness training to your team and plan
ahead for your worst case scenario